something generally speaking when it
comes to sex I think men are a little
more constant you know men like boobs
but we like boobs across the board boob
in the bedroom great boob on the bus
also great dick in the bedroom great
dick on the bus call the police
nobody's calling the police on a boob
see a boob out in the wild it's like
seeing a deer you're like shh
it's Majestic
look there's two now
then your other friend walks up hey look
at that a boob you're like ah you
spooked it
come on
Amber Heard Jada Pinkett all right we
got a couple toxic women here yeah yeah
[Music]
first off I think we should change the
term Karen to Jada first thing and then
uh secondly Amber Heard that that this
[__] trial has been going on for six
years now you know I I just assumed
Chris Brown's watching that going I
would have knocked this [__] out years
ago
[Applause]
like ladies you know when you go to
dinner with a guy like just because you
bought me dinner doesn't mean I owe you
sex and that's true but just because you
let me have sex with you it doesn't mean
I owe my morning
right it's the same exact transaction
equality
I don't know that's why it's weird women
go we're just as horny as men yeah maybe
we have a lot more requirements ladies
quite a checklist you're like the
Goldilocks of Dick this guy's Too Short
this guy's too dumb this guy's just
right guys we'll [__] the porch
I'd say one is better words just
different wait
a doctor he's like what happened I was
like it was too hot
I believe uh women should be paid the
same as men I do I used to work at this
office job one day I walked in this
woman was crying her eyes out she's like
I saw the paychecks I want to be treated
like a man I was like well you want to
be paid like a man you don't be treated
like a man we don't treat each other
well
if you're a tree like a man some guy
would walk in and see you crying be like
hey suck it up [__] what are you doing
oh my God Jesus Christ Rachel's a [__]
Rachel's a [__] ladies you can feed
people that's bananas you got grade a
vitamin D organic milk on tap
we got a cup of coffee right here
bowl of cereal I got you you're a
[__] Dairy
I know a girl she's lactose intolerant
still producing milk
she's making something she can't even
tolerate
much like my mom did with me
because let's be honest prude girls
they're like Mom and Pop shops we all
pretend to like them but they're more
expensive when they close early
promiscuous girls are like Walmart all
right everybody makes fun of them
everybody talks down on them when you're
inside one at four in the morning you're
like man
I'm glad these are around
here what is it
Kardashian hey that's a fun one all
right all right well uh
you know Pete Davidson's in there now
which is impressive because hey that's a
comedian and he's gentrifying her vagina
which is uh you know
it's usually a lot of black in there and
you know a Whitey came in and uh I had
to I had to clean up the neighborhood
you know
that's exciting yeah
Kardashians are fun there's like eight
of them I like them they're they're
they're fun they're [__] they have
fake asses that's cool and they made a
career out of it good for them I say my
ex-girlfriend very paranoid I was going
through my phone sock drawers sniffing
me always looking for Clues that's why
I'm surprised you don't see more female
Detectives
ladies you guys will be amazing at that
you guys are intuitive you're curious
you're persistent I feel like you gals
would crack every case as long as you
thought it was personal
I killed 18 people in Fresno so what
well he's also cheating on your best
friend give me the file a woman can say
something like yeah that guy was good
with his hands he can fix stuff around
the house oh you're cool but if a guy
says hey I like a woman who can cook
people go whoa whoa It's not the 50s
well how come her job for me is okay but
my job for her's not okay also who
doesn't like somebody can fix [__]
around the house
I'd love to come home my girlfriend's
like yeah Bill's a dick [__] right
all right yeah awesome I'll do laundry
yeah
see I think women are you guys are so
smart because you guys made your gender
roles offensive
yeah
that was very clever
well played ladies well played
guys how great would that be if we could
offended hey girlfriend wakes up at 4am
I heard glass shattering somebody break
in you're like well it's not the 50s go
check it out
one of my friends his wife just left him
she walked out after eight years eight
years ago that she walked out because he
knows nothing about her can't say one
fact about his wife so she left good for
her I don't blame her you can describe a
watch for 20 minutes this is a 1941
Submariner super rare Nickel Plate and
I'm like dude if you lose much about
your wife she wouldn't have left that's
why it's weird when I hear women say hey
I'm a person don't treat me like an
object I'm like no no that's what you
want you ever see men with objects
they're obsessed be the best you ever
treated you most guys don't know
anything about their girl he treats like
an object he'll know everything this is
a 1988 Connecticut Jew
I use the term breast implants because I
don't like the term fake breasts I like
to turn it doesn't make sense to me
because the breasts are real it's just
the [__] inside that's fake yeah the
actual breasts are still real it's kind
of like the Bible the book is real it's
just the [__] inside it's fake I told an
abortion joke recently and a woman
approached me she was like hey that's
very insensitive I've had an abortion
you shouldn't tell jokes like that I was
like whoa hey sorry I just told a joke I
think what you did was much worse
foreign
this girl on the date she told me she's
like yeah like a strong silent type
that's what she said to me I find that
offensive
strong silent type if you imagine if a
guy said that what do you look for at a
woman silence
I like open his stuff and shut the [__]
up
get kicked out of society
uh nurses are fun I like nurses because
uh they're they're just [__] and a
Tweety Bird outfit you know they got the
you see a lady in a Tweety Bird's uh
scrub you know she does anal I mean you
know because nurses all they deal with
is needles and bed pans and dead people
I mean they're not going to turn down a
nice uh poke in the pooper right yeah
was that a boo over there what was that
what's that
we love you mark wait what did I do
wow
supporting prostitution yes I've given
them money for years
[Music]
you don't know me you [__] psycho
[__] shut up
so crazy you think you're the good guy
in the movie you know
a [__] [__] all right um oh is that
her oh great all right wait what did I
do why are you mad I don't get it
what do you mean I'm promoting it I'm
telling a joke you [__] psycho Jesus
Christ
I don't think she's smart
suck my dick all right well
that's sexual assault you're promoted
where does it end suck my dick I'm sure
that was transphobic in some way if
we're really uh we're really doing the
numbers here ah should have never [__]
her yeah
[Applause]
I feel like the vagina is a lot like a
university you got to be accepted and
much like University as you get in if
you have a lot of money
you're like well how'd that guy get in
he doesn't have any money well he's an
athlete
[Applause]
are very prestigious like wow you got in
there that's impressive good for you
your other friend's like well I got in
there like well the whole community's
been in there
and you only got engage your dad got it
plus women constantly judged by your
looks that's got to be exhausting
constantly judged by your look but y'all
know how to look good you all look great
that's how women figured out to take the
selfie up here that was all you ladies
you know where your good sight lines are
I think that's why women like tall guys
just some guy looking at you from your
best angle 100 of time all day long
that's why you don't hook up with short
guys just some guy like jeez look at the
triple chit on this broad holy hell